[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regarde regarde la MA viille elle
s'appelle bidon bidon bidon bidon ville
vivre là- dedans c'est coton les viilles
qui ont la peau douce la vende pour
manger dans les chambres l'herbe pousse
pour y dormir faut se pousser les gosses
joue met le ballon c'est une boîte de
sardines
[Musique]
bidon donne-moi ta main camarade toi qui
viens la pays où les hommes sont
beaux donne-moi ta main camarade j'ai
cinq doigts moi aussi on peut se
croireego
bientôt bientôt le soleil dansera
camarade bientôt bientôt je t'attends je
t'attends camarade bientôt bientôt je
t'attends je t'attends
[Musique]
camarade